[Musique]
jean-yves quand on fait des impostures
est ce que finalement c'est aussi pour
être un peu polémiste est ce que la
télévision ça devient l'écriture
d'aujourd'hui et et qu'il ya quelques
siècles tu aurais pu être écrivain
enfin c'est quoi je crois qu'il ya
quelques siècles c'est peut-être plus
tôt en trouver à la bastille ouais ouais
non je pense que c'est c'est pas
simplement ces deux là nan je crois pas
être un peu les pistes
je crois juste que je peux pas faire
autre chose que ce que je fais ce que
les gens quand même tu es très dure
vis-à-vis des jeux moment exact et je me
moque pas des gens je me moque de nous
oui à deux des autres et de nous de nous
en général ça peut mais moi je fais
gaffe dans la ville effectivement a pas
faire de faux témoignages a pas faire de
délation parler alors parlons de ça il
ya des sketches très dur que tu as pu
faire effectivement tout d'un coup tu
prends quelqu'un à témoins et ça devient
de l'ordre du faux témoignage
un sale et c'est très rock and roll
quand même ouais mais moi je me trouve
pas du tout le même
il faut tous que c'est un tract
rapidement très rapidement je lui fait
croire que
on est en direct pour le journal de 13h
et qu'il ya eu une mère qui à la fenêtre
a laissé tomber son gamin dans la rue
donc est tombé dans un arbre peu et que
malheureusement il n'y a pas de témoin
ce qui pourrait raconter la scène et
tout au début il veut pas faire de faux
témoignage mais il pense qu'on est des
flics ou quoi on n'en sait rien avec des
caméras en plus tu vois ce que tout ça
se passe en évidemment devant les
caméras et puis il finit par raconter
qu'il a entendu un cri qui l'a sauvé
l'enfant n'a que huit langues mais je
lui demande quand même de faire un faux
témoignage
ce mec là son été en 40 très bien de
quoi il est capable
j'ai en moi je me trouve pas dur de
faire faire ça il peut se marrer quand
même il a pas les menottes aux mains
pour faire son faux témoignage il est
libre c'est comme au téléphone typique
pour accrocher le fail envie de le faire
une femme et nacion super ne sais pas
moi d'assumer son faux témoignage
d'accord encore autre chose au téléphone
et ça on le retrouve donc dans cet album
dont on parle mort de rire les
impostures de la fesse il y a cette le
voyeur s'appelle le voyez ouais alors
bon alors ça faut le rappeler c'est quoi
ce sketch rapidement donc ôter les
femmes donc j'appelle en expliquant que
je suis voisin du monsieur et que j'aime
bien regarder avec musulmane ce qui se
passe en face de chez moi
particulier j'aime bien dans les gens d
habiller tout ça je lui demande s'il
accepterait le soir entre 22 heures et
22h15 de s'exhiber donc nue pour moi à
sa fenêtre
alors début de mai qu'il manque mais
vous êtes un vicieux sans fin mon nom je
suis pas officielle mais toi je lui
propose du free qui a refusé tout et
puis ils croient moins connaître ils
croient que je suis le prothésiste qui
l'a vu pisser dans un lavabo
donc conclusion je rappelle en faisant
passer pour au service des écoutes
téléphoniques et donc je suis flic et je
lui demande pourquoi c'est ce voyeur de
s'exhiber à 22h le soir et le mec
accepte parce que je suis flic 1 et il
va même s'exhiber dans un appareil et un
accoutrement qu'on laisse aux gens le
soin de soi le soin de découvrir dans
cet album bon est-ce que c'est pas
finalement faire un petit peu ce qui
s'est toujours fait à la radio
c'est à dire la blague téléphonique mais
avec avec quand même quelque chose de
beaucoup plus dur dans sa manière
d'aborder le rire finalement ces tarifs
craint non metavante un vrai talent
c'est sûr que tu as vrai qu'après ça
veut dire que tu as raison wen tu as
raison mais c'est pas moi qui suis dur
c'est l'époque qui est dur c'est pas moi
moi je m'amuse avec ce que j'ai je
n'invente pas me laisser le prix elles
sont là toujours bon il faut bien je
m'amusais que ça on a le droit de rire
de tout et germaine plus qu'il faut rire
de tout qui ça soulage se fait du bien
[Musique]